the palestinian village of duma nestled
among olive groves lies in the
israeli-occupied west bank
zakaria sada is on a return visit he
works for the Israeli group rabbis for
human rights by documenting attacks by
Jewish settlers family and that's what
the dr oz it was the ugliest thing I've
ever seen he says it's hard to describe
what I found in the village when I got
there just an hour after the attack how
could someone burn a house where a
family is sleeping apollomon saw a
better than feel a family this is what
remains of the dropship family home many
here have a so-called price tag attacks
story to tell that's the name given to
hate crimes by fundamentalist Jewish
settlers who say it's the price
Palestinians have to pay when the
expansion of Israeli settlements is
slowed or limited nanobot occasional a.j
soto decide the soldiers of the Israeli
army are not doing their jobs he says
what I optical oh oh they do nothing to
stop the terrorists settlers and the
price tag people sit on the year must
what the [ __ ] man well heard I was so
bad that's why they keep doing what
they've done before a capital letter
donald morton you but up in the hills
the view is different these Jewish
settler outposts near the settlement of
Shiloh are illegal but they're tolerated
by authorities it's from places like
these that hardline Jewish nationalist
groups like hilltop youth are said to
operate police searched a number of
homes over the weekend provoking anger
in the settlement outpost of ash Kadesh
sheep shearing going pomogi without the
people who live here are also sad about
what happened he says referring to the
attack on the dropship family it's
morally reprehensible it's unju and it's
done a great deal of damage to Israel
and the Jewish community in this area
she's a bowfin court being held
collectively responsible for something
we didn't do an emotion cachet 11am is
our thing but these outposts continue to
grow under the guard of Israeli soldiers
Yehuda Hendler is here out of conviction
that Judea and Samaria as the settlers
here call the land or Jewish territory
he suggests these price tag attacks are
rooted in frustration I you didn't build
up some 1v on those people with whom I
do not identify see how the Israeli
government treats us in Judea and
Samaria he says I'm sure they're all
over they don't help us and they do
nothing against Arabic terrorism we feel
unwanted and these people feel pushed
around by the state that's why they
decide to do something and carry out
these so-called price tag attacks yes
Volusion Tecna field one of the best
known hilltop youth leaders is my year
ettinger he's been in custody since
tuesday though it's not clear if he
played a part in the fatal arson attack
since then authorities in Jerusalem have
spoken of a zero-tolerance policy a task
force against Jewish extremism has been
in existence for some time but only a
few cases have been solved the
government has taken a decision to treat
this sort of Jewish extremist violence
in the same way we treat Palestinian
violence both the terrorism both must be
fought and most both must be defeated
the Israeli army has beefed up patrols
throughout the occupied West Bank fears
of revenge attacks from both sides are
running high